Vanessa is in New Orleans welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show Vanessa
thanks Dave I've been a listener for a
long time I'm delighted to talk to you
well you too thank you for listening how
can I help
recently I received an inheritance for
my grandfather and my parents and my
situation has changed quite a bit from
when I first started listening to you
because I was married at the time and we
had a really good income and went
through Financial Peace University and
did really great but fast forward a
decade later I'm in a new situation a
new relationship I brought in quite a
bit of debt into this relationship and
my boyfriend at the time is supporting
me while I finished my internship for
graduate school
the plan was once I graduated I would
start paying off on my debt but so now I
am trying to decide what do I do with
inheritance it's only 15,000 it wouldn't
even put it in and one of my student
loans so I'm trying to decide to put it
in a money market account so I'll put it
in the CD because I definitely want it I
want to try to be smart with my money
this time and I want to make sure that I
have kind of a safety net if I do find
myself you know back on my own again
and I don't get the job that I
anticipate getting when I graduate so I
guess you know wanted to reach out to
you and see what your thoughts are when
you do you get a little extra cushion
but it's not enough to cover the
existing that you already have mm-hmm
well if you were working the baby steps
you would apply to the debt but right
now it's on hold while you're in school
and you're broke
right yes and so you're not you're not
working them right now I wouldn't be if
I were you I think you're wise to do
that so what are you studying I am
studying clinical mental health I'm
working towards my license to be a
professional therapist darn it and when
will you graduate I graduated in May oh
good good
and is that is the is everything paid
for through May as far as my just daily
expenses or monthly you know your your
education the tuition yes currently
where my boys and I are
payin cash for it okay do you work I
have a couple of side jobs I'm a tour
guide for my city and I babysit that it
basically covers my car insurance and
gas otherwise he covers all of our
expenses he's paying for your tuition
yes sir and the intent that I will when
we when I finish I'm going to set
something up to pay him back but he is
floating me right now while I finish is
it's pretty much a full-time seeing
clients commuting assignments research
it's 40 plus hours a week that I put
into it you're going into debt to your
boyfriend yes no what will it cost to
finish school have you paid for it
it would pretty much drain my
inheritance it will take about about
another six or seven grand to finish and
you of the 15 yeah I don't think I want
you to add to your to anybody I don't
want you continually going in debt with
$15,000 laying in your account so I
would pay cash for myself if you're
married it's completely different but
you're not married right no if you're
married his money's your money's his
money's your money but you're not
married so you're borrowing money from
this guy that's just bad I'm not gonna
tell you to continue that I would use
the money to not add any more debt to
your situation finish your degree and
then start your baby steps which is to
begin to clear up all your debts which
is your existing student loans plus your
debt to your boyfriend and you start to
clean those up when you graduate in May
get licensed and get you know get your
get your real therapists job at that
point and start making some money but no
I'm not gonna put money in an account
and borrow money from your boyfriend no
not a chance